.
>> WILL: THANKS, BILL.
PETE: LET'S BRING IN KEN PAXTON,
TEXAS ATTORNEY GENERAL.
MR. ATTORNEY GENERAL, THANKS FOR
BEING HERE.
WE'VE BEEN TRYING TO GET A PLAN,
OR  MAYBE THE PLAN IS NO PLAN,
THAT'S BEEN THE PLAN SO FAR, OUT
OF THE WHITE HOUSE FOR WHAT
HAPPENS AFTER TITLE 42.
WHAT'S TEXAS' PLAN WHEN THE
FLOOD GATES OPEN FOR ILLEGAL
S?
>> SO THIS WAS THE LAST VESTAGE
OF ANY TYPE OF FEDERAL
LAW THAT WOULD PROTECT US FROM
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION OVER
THE LAST TWO YEARS WAS STOPPING
THE BUILDING OF THE WALL,
WHETHER IT'S CONTINUING CATCH
AND RELEASE, WHETHER IT'S THE
REMAIN IN MEXICO PROGRAM,
WHETHER IT'S TITLE 42, THEY HAVE
ANNOUNCED LITERALLY ON DAY ONE
THEY WOULD STOP DEPORTATIONS.
THEY HAVE DISMANTLED FEDERAL LAW
BY THEMSELVES, NOT WITH THE
APPROVAL OF CONGRESS SO IT'S
VERY IMPORTANT WE GOT THIS
VICTORY REMAIN IN MEXICO.
THIS IS OUR BEST HOPE OF
PROTECTING THE PEOPLE OF TEXAS,
AND THE PEOPLE OF THIS COUNTRY
FROM ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION AND THE
CONSEQUENCES THAT BILL
MELUGIN JUST TALKED ABOUT.
>> WILL: MR. ATTORNEY GENERAL,
I HAVE TO ASK THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS ACTING LIKE
THEY HAVE A PLAN.
THERE'S SOMETHING THEY ARE GOING
TO UNVEIL.
YOU WOULD THINK THEY BE
COORDINATING WITH, FOR
EXAMPLE, PERHAPS A BORDER STATE
LIKE TEXAS.
DO YOU HAVE ANY INDICATION OF
THEIR PLAN IF TITLE 42 EXPIRES?
>> YOU KNOW THAT'S BEEN THE
FRUSTRATING PART ABOUT
DEALING WITH THEM.
THERE ARE MASSIVE CONSEQUENCES
TO OUR STATE WHETHER YOU TALK
ABOUT THE DRUGS THAT BILL
MELUGIN WAS REFERRING TO OR
JUST THE MASSIVE INFLUX OF
ILLEGALS AND THE CONSEQUENCES OF
THAT.
WE'VE NEVER BEEN GIVEN
INFORMATION ABOUT A PLAN, AND I
DON'T SURVEILLANCES WE'RE GOING
TO GET ONE THIS TIME AND I'M
VERY SUSPICIOUS OF ANY SO-CALLED
PLAN THAT THEY HAVE NOT SHARED
WITH THE BORDER STATES.
OBVIOUSLY, IT EFFECTS US ON A
DAILY BASIS WITH FIVE, SIX,
7,000 PEOPLE A DAY CROSSING THE
BORDER.
RACHEL: LET ME ASK YOU THIS ,
BECAUSE THIS IS A STATEMENT FROM
ABDULA HASSAN, THE
ASSISTANT WHITE HOUSE PRESS
SECRETARY.
HE SAYS TO BE CLEAR, THE LIFTING
OF THE TITLE 42 PUBLIC HEALTH
ORDER DOES NOT MEAN THE BORDER
IS OPEN.
ANYONE WHO SUGGESTS OTHERWISE IS
DOING THE WORK OF SMUGGLERS AND
SPREADING MISINFORMATION TO MAKE
A QUICK BUCK OFF OF VULNERABLE
MIGRANTS.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THAT?
>> I JUST SAY LOOK AT THE FACTS
AND WE HAD OVER 2 MILLION PEOPLE
CROSS THE BORDER LAST FISCAL
YEAR.
WE'VE HAD SINCE THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TOOK OVER THE
PRESIDENCY, OVER 300%
INCREASE IN ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
I MEAN, THE NUMBERS SPEAK FOR
THEMSELVES SO THIS IDEA THAT
SOMEHOW TITLE 42 GOING AWAY
WHICH WE KNOW IS GOING TO CAUSE
A MASSIVE INFLUX BECAUSE WHAT
THEY ARE NOW GOING TO DO, THAT
WAS OUR OWN REMAINING VESTAGE OF
SOME TYPE OF LAW THAT PREVENTED
PEOPLE FROM COMING ACROSS AND
CLAIMING ASYLUM SO NOW THEY COME
ACROSS AND CLAIM ASYLUM.
THAT'S WHY THE REMAIN IN MEXICO
IS SO IMPORTANT.
THAT'S THE PROVISION OF THE LAW
THAT DEALS WITH ASYLUM AND
MAKING PEOPLE STAY IN THEIR
COUNTRY OF ORIGIN OR  BE
DETAINED UNTIL THEY GET TO THEIR
HEARING.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION WANTS
TO JUST LET THEM ALL IN, SEND
THEM TO WHERE THEY GO AND HOPE
SOME DAY THEY HAVE A HEARING.
PETE: SO MR. ATTORNEY GENERAL,
WE KNOW THERE'S NO PLAN.
WE KNOW TITLE 42 IS EXPIRING AND
YOU AREN'T GETTING SUPPORT FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
LET'S JUST SET THAT ASIDE AS A
GIVEN.
WE KNOW AN EVEN LARGER INVASION
IS COMING.
YOUR JOB AND THE GOVERNORS JOB
IS TO SAFEGUARD THE CITIZENS OF
TEXAS SO SORT OF ASK AGAIN, LIKE
WHAT IS THE NEW APPROACH TEXAS
CAN TAKE IN LIGHT OF THIS
INVASION?
IT'S UNSUSTAINABLE, IT ERASES
OUR SOVEREIGNTY.
ARE THERE MORE TOOLS YOU HAVEN'T
YET USED THAT YOU CAN DO TO
SAFEGUARD YOUR STATE?
>> SO WE'VE GOT THE LEGAL
THINGS I JUST TALKED ABOUT.
WE ARE ARRESTING PEOPLE THAT ARE
CROSSING ILLEGALLY THAT WE CAN
ARREST FOR STATE LAW VIOLATIONS.
THE PROBLEM IS, THE WAY THAT IT
USED TO WORK IS PEOPLE THAT COME
ACROSS THE BORDER WERE
TRYING TO HIDE FROM BORDER
PATROL AND COMING ACROSS ALL
TYPES OF AREAS TRYING TO AVOID
EVADING THE BORDER PATROL AND
NOW, BECAUSE OF THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, THE CARTELS KNOW
, HEY THERE'S A DEAL HERE.
JUST BRING AS MANY PEOPLE AS
POSSIBLE TO THE --
PETE: THEY WANT TO BE FOUND.
>> YES, TO THE BORDER PATROL
AND THEY TURN THEMSELVES IN
WHICH PUTS US IN A DIFFICULT
SPOT, BECAUSE NOW, IT'S THE
CARTELS WORKING WITH BORDER
PATROL, NOT THEIR FAULT, BECAUSE
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS TOLD
TO DO THAT AND THEN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION TAKES IT FROM
THEM SO THERE'S NOWHERE FOR
TEXAS TO INTERVENE.
THIS IS ALL SETUP TO MAKE IT
IMPOSSIBLE FOR US TO STOP
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION.
RACHEL: ATTORNEY GENERAL, I HAVE
A QUESTION FOR YOU.
I WAS DOWN IN TEXAS NOT TOO LONG
AGO, AND A LOCAL JOURNALIST
THERE SAID THE REAL STORY IS THE
NGO'S.
THE REAL STORY IS THE MONEY
GOING THERE.
THE WAY THEY'RE HIRING PEOPLE
WITHIN THE  NGO'S TO VET PEOPLE.
SHE SAID SHE TOLD ME THERE WAS
JUST LIKE HIGH SCHOOL KIDS THAT
RECENT GRADUATES THAT ARE NOW
DOING THE JOB OF VETTING PEOPLE
COMING TO OUR COUNTRY AND THEY
ARE DOING IT WITHIN 24 HOURS.
I PERSONALLY WITNESSED AT AN
AIRPORT PEOPLE COMING FROM
THE DOMINICAN REPUBLIC WHO HAVE
ONLY BEEN IN OUR COUNTRY FOR 24
HOURS SO WHOSE DOING THE VETTING
TALK TO ME ABOUT THE  NGO'S AND
THE RESPONSIBILITY THEY BEAR AND
THEIR ROLE IN THIS ENTIRE OPEN
BORDER POLICY FROM THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
>> YEAH, AND THAT'S A GREAT
QUESTION.
THESE NON-GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATIONS WE BELIEVE ARE
PARTICIPATING IN VIOLATING OUR
STATE AND FEDERAL LAWS AND WE'RE
ACTUALLY STARTING TO LOOK AT
THAT.
WE'VE ALREADY HAD AN
INVESTIGATION BELIEVE IT OR
NOT OF OUR TEXAS STATE BAR
FOUNDATION THAT WE BELIEVE ARE
PARTICIPATING AND HELPING PEOPLE
COME HERE ILLEGALLY AND NOT
DOING IT THE RIGHT WAY SO WE
STARTED THAT INVESTIGATION
SEVERAL MONTHS AGO.
WE JUST STEPPED THAT UP AND
WE'RE LOOKING FOR INFORMATION
ABOUT OTHER
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS SO
WE'LL SEE IF THERE'S A WAY WE
CAN AT LEAST INHIBIT SOME OF
THESE NON-GOVERNMENT ENTITIES
FROM DOING ILLEGAL WORK FOR THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT OR
FOR WHOEVER.
>> WILL: MR. ATTORNEY GENERAL
I'D LOVE TO ASK YOU ONE FOLLOW
YOU'LL TO PETE'S QUESTION ABOUT
THE TOOLS AT YOUR DISPOSAL.
WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOU COMING
ON AND ANSWERING THESE QUESTIONS
, AND I THINK WE'RE ALL
ON THE SAME SIDE OF HOPING TO
SOLVE WHAT SEEMS TO BE AN
IMPOSSIBLE OR  MAYBE NOT
IMPOSSIBLE, AN UNWILLING ISSUE
OF THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO
SOLVE, AND THAT IS A FEW WEEKS
AGO, A MONTH AGO, YOU GOT IN
TEXAS YOU DECLARED THE GOVERNOR
THE DECLARATION OF AN INVASION.
A VAILING NEW POWERS IN HIS
STATEMENT FOR THE STATE TO
DEPORT ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS TO THE
BORDER.
IT WAS CRITICIZED BY SOME LIKE
KEN CUCINELLI, WHO SAID THERE'S
NO POINT IN TAKING SOMEBODY TO
THE BORDER.
YOU HAVE TO TAKE SOMEBODY ACROSS
THE BORDER FOR IT TO BE
EFFECTIVE.
WHAT I WOULD LOVE TO ASK YOU
TODAY IS A, YOUR RESPONSE TO
THAT AND B, HAVE YOU SEEN ANY
APPRECIATABLE EFFECT AFTER YOU
DECLARED THAT INVASION IN
HELPING THIS CRISIS?
>> YEAH, AND IT GOES BACK TO
THE CHALLENGE THAT I TALKED
ABOUT.
MOST OF THE PEOPLE ARE NOT
TRYING TO EVADE BORDER PATROL.
THEY ARE GOING DIRECTLY TO
BORDER PATROL, SO THE IDEA OF
DECLARING AN EVASION IS, IT'S A
FACT.
I MEAN, IT IS AND IT SHOULD GIVE
US THE AUTHORITY TO DO MORE.
WE HAVE TWO CHALLENGES.
ONE, THE FACT THEY ARE BRINGING
PEOPLE TO THE BORDER BUT THEY
ARE BRINGING THEM TO BORDER
PATROL WHICH TAKES US OUT OF THE
EQUATION AND SECOND, WE
STILL HAVE THIS SUPREME COURT
DECISION, ARIZONA VS. U.S. THAT
WAS DECIDED UNDER UNDER THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION THAT
SAID THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HAD
COMPLETE CONTROL OVER THE BORDER
WE NEED TO CHALLENGE THAT SO
WE'RE LOOKING FOR ANGLES WHERE
ONE OF OUR STATE GOVERNMENT
OFFICIALS WHETHER IT'S THE
LEGISLATURE OR  THE .
>> GOVERNOR: FOR VIOLATES THAT,
WE GET SUED AND THEN WE CAN TAKE
IT BACK UP AND SAY HEY, THAT
DECISION CAN'T BE RIGHT.
IT CANNOT BE RIGHT THAT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CAN HAVE
ITS OWN LAWS, AVOID ENFORCING
THEM AND THEN SAY THAT THE
STATES CAN'T PROTECT
THEMSELVES BY AVAILING
THEMSELVES OF THE SAME LAW IT
DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE BECAUSE
OTHERWISE THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
JUST PASSES LAWS AND THERE'S
REALLY NO CONSEQUENCE OTHER THAN
TO SAY NOW THE STATES CAN'T
PROTECT THEMSELVES.
THAT CAN NOT BE THE RIGHT
OUTCOME.
>> WILL: ACTIVELY LOOKING FOR
THAT CANS FUSION ALL
CHALLENGE.
PETE: ATTORNEY GENERAL